bilal franchement des très heureux de te
voir et le livre mobile al hassani
singulier tu parles de beaucoup beaucoup
de choses notamment à l'école tu dis que
c'était très dur pour toi avant
d'arrêter l'école à quel âge j'ai fait
mon bac
il avait fait un deal avec ma maman
quand j'avais 8 ans l'été en train de
manger du poisson et je les dis maman
moi je vais être chanteur je veux pas
aller à l'école c'est nul les maths
elle m'a dit tu oses tu vas t'entraîner
d'abord et tu passe ton bac à partir de
mon but at on pas que tu fais ce que tu
veux c'est ça et donc on a tenu enfin
j'ai tenu cette promesse j'ai eu un bac
l littéraire aujourd'hui bien sûr
personne singulier lagarde et michard
entendu les lettres de mon moulin a
entendu j'en passe et des meilleurs
l'ami de maupassant bel ami
donc j'ai arrêté l'école j'ai fait trois
quatre mois d'université après ça va se
jouer à ça tu as toulalan lundi tu dis à
l'école c'est toi qui le dit dans le
livre tu dis où te reprocher de rouler
du cul ouais je voulais pas du cuse
était genre en fait j'avais 7 ans à ce
moment là donc je ne savais même pas ce
que je ferai ma démarche naturelle et il
trouvait que je marchais comme une fille
et j'ai eu cet épisode un peu
traumatisant pour moi que je raconte
dans le livre où j'étais à la piscine
municipale avec ma maman qui était loin
là en train de faire sa vie et mon frère
dans la piscine moi j'avais peur de
l'eau d'origine âgé pas et je voulais
aller aux toilettes et à mes camarades
de classe qui m'ont vu et ils ont
commencé à se [ __ ] de moi mais
arrivent très très fort et j'étais un
peu tout ça dans mon truc je suis devenu
tout rouge et donc c'est là que j'ai
commencé vraiment à à camoufler un petit
peu mais là les craintes que j'avais le
raid que j'étais triste parce que je
pensais qu'être triste c'était mauvais
donc je garder la tête haute et
j'avançais comme ça malgré le fait
qu'ils étaient en train de m'insulter et
c'est là que j'ai commencé un petit peu
à apprendre c'est certain tony sipp à
terme en de confiance et serrer la vis
là tu te livre vachement de dont tu
parle même de ta première fois un oui
c'est ouf non non si je voulais faut
lire les noms mais on met deux minutes
ce que c'est bien sympa la de manger des
sandwichs mais c'est dur je vais le lire
si tu manges et du bouffey autant de
sandwiches que tu lisais de bouquins je
peux dire qu'aujourd'hui tu présenteras
foa post of conan donc j'en parle je
t'en parle évidemment mais c'était pas
juste pour en parler
j'ai même pas envie de parler de ma
première fois juste pour parler de ma
première fois c'était pas ce n'était pas
le but mais c'était vraiment les quais
c'est pour toutes les personnes qui vont
qui fait ça je pense voilà je parle est
un petit peu là parce que moi j'étais un
jeune garçon qui commençait à découvrir
sa sexualité au collège et quand on est
homosexuel dans un dans un bahut où on
est le seul homosexuel c'est un petit
peu on n'a pas de relation il n'ya pas
les petites amourettes d'école on se
tient la main et on se fait le bisou sur
la joue et c'est moi j'avais pas le
droit à ça
et donc ça arrive à beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont dans mon cas est qui et qui
sont pas hétéro il voit d'un seul coup
confronté à l'aspect plus vulgaire en
fête de l'amour et à ce côté très
sexuelle et genres
allez assez étonnante c'est que c'était
avec un garçon qui est avec qui et avec
une fiancée qui était avec un garçon qui
était qui et c'est un garçon qui était
quelqu'un qui est telle qu'elle est une
jeune fille katey le monde aime je suis
désolé qu'ils étaient qui était ton ami
et il paraît que voilà il s'est dit
voilà quel âge il a 13 ans et 13 ans et
demi et il paraît que j'avais eu une
aventure ensemble une après il est
retourné avec avec salah et ça a fait
suer ça a créé des grosses complications
dans mon établissement
malgré le fait que c'était juste une
rumeur mais ce n'était pas vrai mais
voilà après en fait non mais c'était
vrai mais en gros pourrait pour le corps
à part à part lui et moi personne ne
savait si c'était vrai ou faux c'est
vrai j'ai su me dirai donc tout le monde
en parlait et ça a beaucoup engrais nsa
a fait que après mais il me dit partir
du nom j'ai dû quitter l'établissement
et pas lui juste moi et donc c'était un
peu compliqué après voilà c'était à 13
ans j'étais très très jeune j'ai
beaucoup de regrets par rapport à ça
dans ma tête je n'ai jamais que j'allais
en parler publiquement
mais si je désire c'est parce que
vraiment ce n'était pas quelque chose
que j'avais envie de faire et j'ai été
un petit peu mis dedans et c'était
c'était dur en fait à vivre mais sur le
moment je me rendais pas compte et avec
du recul je me rends compte que c'est
être autant en fait